which platform has had the biggest
impact on your career
i would say netflix for sure definitely
um
the the audience you can reach like uh
and i know it's weird to say because
i've i've had uh theatrical releases as
well but
um because it's such a huge
global audience i think uh um
yeah i think netflix is amazing the the
reach they have
um is uh is a pretty
it's pretty extraordinary what they've
built and so um
and nowadays i i in certain instances i
prefer
like uh netflix over a theatrical run
like depending on um
the cities and like the probably the
amount of marketing put behind it but
um yeah i think i think theaters and
netflix are
very close right now
um but yeah i'd say
i said netflix for sure are there
certain cities that are surprisingly
um the surprisingly well received your
films
that most people would think oh i
wouldn't expect that to
be a big market huh um i actually had a
theatrical release in korea
um with call me king actually
um yeah we were in theaters in korea
we're in theaters in africa uh
and in north america and um yeah i had
some
friends some korean friends who called
me
on the way to the theater like hey we're
going to see your movie you know and
i thought that was really cool man
because i'm a huge fan of korean cinema
i think they're amazing storytellers and
so
yeah i think the korean market south
korean market
specifically it's been interesting
to see like the the reaction
it's had there
[Music]
so that was that was a unique place
south america very much so and then
north america but also korea like uh
um has been uh i think korean has been
the most interesting
yeah when call me king was on netflix
did you see a lot of people reaching out
to you on social media emails
yeah absolutely um and what was
interesting too is a lot of the
actors in the film they got a lot of uh
energy from uh fans of the movie like
rather be in in in person or
or online yeah a lot of us
got a lot of
i got quite a few jobs from it
but um but yeah a lot of people sort of
reaching out
and um finding the film
it trended for a long time uh on
on netflix was really cool but i think a
lot of that had to do with the
um the viral uh scene from it but
um but yeah i think there was a there
was a big sort of
influx of uh people reaching out
uh who saw the film um industry people
as well
um yeah i think i think up to that point
that had
been like my biggest film uh
up to that point uh as far as um
reach and i think what it did uh the
reaction it got
um from the industry for sure
so were there other films that you did
that where you expected
it to go the way call me king did
because you know
some people say like you can't
orchestrate anything viral
and there's so many times when you think
something's gonna be huge and it's not
and then vice versa because of the
relationship aspect of that one scene
and people debating and then they go
i need to see this i want to know who
the filmmaker is yeah
um well i mean comey king was the last
film i did before lazarus
so um lazarus isn't out yet but
like the anticipation of it is really
high like uh
you know um i've already gotten like a
lot of
jobs just on the trailer
a lot of meetings things are looking
really good as far as
like we have a lot of options as far as
distribution
and so um yeah there's a there's a
there's already sort of started to be
like a
groundswell you know we haven't put out
the trailer yet
but we will pretty soon the movie is
going to come out this summer
and yeah i'm expecting some
some good results uh from it
um most definitely yeah when people
wrote to you about call me king what
were they
writing to you about like what were they
did they have questions do they just
want to praise you
um there were quite a few accolades but
also um
people were um just happy to see
um it sort of exists in the action crime
genre
um like similar to like goodfellas or
the godfather sort of in that space
but it was the first time people had
seen like
this type of approach like i was saying
earlier with
them being haitian uh with them being
gun runners but they
but they were very refined you know they
they uh
spoke different languages they they wore
suits and they
um spoke very eloquently they uh
there was a really cool scene in the
film where
um one of our lead characters are he's
talking to his brother but he's sort of
telling him how
bourbon is made you know how
it actually it's clear when it starts
and then the reason it turns brown is
because it's uh
curated is cured in wooden barrels and
so the wood is what
gives the bourbon its color like it
changes color
uh from clear to uh to to this
this brown color because of the way it's
it's it's made and so he was using it as
an analogy um
and how like if you leave it too long
it'll
um lose uh integrity and so he was he's
he's sort of breaking down this
this i these ideals to him but he's
using bourbon as a way to do it
so um people were like really uh
they're like wow like that's different
you know like we haven't seen that yet
like you know
um the uh you know they're not drug
dealers they're gun runners
so i just wanted to sort of uh create
something in the crime genre but
do it in it in a way um
that may represent like uh characters we
haven't seen in this genre before like
uh
and um do it in a
a more a a more unique approach than i
guess we may have seen from
a lot of films that um when you see
people of color in
those films in that genre you you expect
it to be a lot more
uh hood i guess a street um
and not as refined and so i wanted to
sort of
challenge that idea um
and so i think i think some people um
found that to be like really interesting